[Music]
in what really happened news submitted
by Farhan potato lover three teams
created outrage online after taunting a
homeless man
it's that Logan Paul effect oh noes are
they dead were they doing homeless
awareness I think that's what they were
doing it had to be doing homeless
awareness and afterwards they tapped it
out directed it throw pokeballs out
homeless people no trying to catch the
problems away here we go I am you're not
homeless anymore taxes so this all
started with this woman's Facebook post
this woman named Sally this all takes
place in the UK by the way Oh Sally she
post these photos of these girls like
here's one of them and it's all blurred
out cuz they're underage oh there's
three girls here and then there was
another photo which I don't have access
to cuz she deleted the post it was girls
that did it yeah three girls so this is
what she wrote just too much man
no writing or the story right have you
ever seen this [ __ ] sometimes it's like
people write like novels and I go that's
too much on me TL DR I read books cuz I
know what I'm getting alright but if
you're not a good author [ __ ] you you
wasting my time but go ahead since
you're gonna read it I'll listen
yeah just listing out the word about
reading alright she says I can't believe
what myself and other people just
witnessed and Woolwich this evening
three loud girls came storming in with
their cameras filming and taking pics of
a homeless man strolling along behind
and they were saying we are going to pay
for your dinner and buy you Nando's I
absolutely love what is Nando's
peri-peri chicken yes oh but it's the
best in the world
yeah it's juicy I don't know why now
doesn't don't want to come here to
American States of America but it's
juicy I've continued they told the man
to sit down and the three girls went to
the counter and was talking to the staff
they then said they ordered his food and
they was going outside for a cigarette
he asked what did you order and
kept laughing everyone in Nando's was
looking at them because of how loud they
were being and this bright flash they
had from their phones recording what was
happening the man seemed suspicious so
he went to the counter and asked what
they had ordered and they was shaking
their head saying the girls didn't order
anything for him the man looked so upset
and apologized to the workers the girls
were outside recording him and laughing
hysterically while recording him as he
was walking out they had no intention of
ordering him any food instead they
followed him and laughing and
terrorizing him absolutely disgusting I
hope you are all proud and it made you
feel good about yourselves it's a pretty
bro so then Sally says that she tried
like she bought the guy food and then
like this all blew up on Facebook then
one of the girls the one of these Street
girls she ends up saying this so she
says lol for everyone talking my name
and talking [ __ ] actually know what was
going on I'm a 17 year old girl yeah and
we walked out of McDonald's and he'd
come up to us and approached us asking
for a [ __ ] which I guess is the cigarette
yep I do not smoke I told him no he was
he wasn't happy and said I can buy him a
drink we got him a drink it wasn't good
enough for him he wanted more I told him
to leave me alone and my friends and he
won't
and he wounding started telling my
friend how he would do things to her so
I walked in to Nando's walked to the bar
and told the man we are pretending to
order food so the man leaves us alone
and the man on the counter went along
with it he we said we were going outside
to my friends so he can smoke and then
they walked out and then we walked away
he came out and started shouting at us
saying that you you guys are liars and
he grabbed my friend so she started
defending herself and pushed him away
and I he's a fully grown man what am I
supposed to do a man even told him to
leave us alone
and then like this whole thing right so
she's like that's the other side of the
story she doesn't smoke how come they
went outside to smoke yeah
they like the way everything's right
miss yeah we written so then Sally ends
up saying no that's not the story there
was six witnesses including me you was
terrorizing him all down the street you
three were bio you wasn't scared you
wasn't scared I would have been the
first to help if that was the case he
was bullying and taking the mickey out
of a homeless man he sat down freezing
cold expecting you to get him something
to eat and then you just left laughing
and filming him Karma so that's the
whole story
this is Sally so now it's Sally saying
that she's getting death threats Oh from
people that are saying that she should
have never talked shirts of those throws
in the first place why what's going on
they do things different the UK huh I'm
so confused
she's gets death threats for talking
[ __ ] that's so crazy she didn't know she
was there as a witness yeah so then to
my knowledge no one else has come
forward saying like yeah that's true
what's that leasing so we really don't
know the whole story dad
threats though like who's gonna invest
and spend their time trying to kill this
woman or no real reason does the person
that's given a debt that wasn't there
either yeah they're saying that Sally
should have never posted this in the
first place that she shouldn't have been
shaming these teams online why I guess
these people believe the girl's story
how can you believe either one is a
confusing else's story I mean I lean
more towards Sally because it makes more
sense logically logically it just makes
more sense versus the what does it make
more sense I mean first of all she could
write English yeah the other one was
well first of all there's no flaws in
her logic it's just straight up this is
what I witnessed the girls were
basically taunting this man and it's
very specific
taunting this man they went inside no
food and then you can see like oh I can
see how that happens they you date they
were doing it for YouTube views they're
doing it for whatever it's a prank
whatever right the girls it's kind of
like if they were being harassed by this
man
in some way shape or form why would
Sallie even come up with something
that's totally opposite you know you
were the you were not the victims here
you were the ones taunting this man it's
like totally different and she said he
asked for a cigarette we said we didn't
have one after that we went out to go
have a cigarette yeah that that's the
part I was like wait why don't you just
give him a cigarette then and then he'll
be on his way
didn't you bought him a drink somewhere
else and then you what you bought like I
don't know it doesn't make any sense
yeah if maybe because she's young she
doesn't know how to explain herself if
she says something like this do is
bothering us so we started recording it
because we were scared yeah yeah but in
there would be no reason why Sally or
witnesses would say you are bullying a
homeless man like what a salad games if
you were so scared why were you laughing
yeah everyone everyone would be little
sense that you're scared to know and
they will try to help you but they were
recording him with the phone and
laughing so that's the the weird
particle that's that has nothing to do
with fear but now Sal he's just saying
that you know now she just feels like
this whole thing like this whole
backlash with like the online backlash
like because now she's being branded as
it cuts for posting the footage wait
there's footage there is I don't I don't
have that footage so who recorded what
Sal yeah we recorded the girls okay then
the girls also must have some footage
right if she if she's saying that the
girls recorded all this stuff where's
all that stuff if the girls want to
clear their name all they gotta do is
upload that video this guy's been
following me the whole time whatever
whatever oh yeah yeah well based on the
information I have like if no one's
mentioned like the girls side like the
girls video being surfaced or and then I
don't have the footage their original
footage that Sally posted
so I think Nando's is behind this the
marketing marketing Fernando conspiracy
I can think about right now is that
peri-peri chicken that Nando's has with
all the different sauces
that's all I can think about you got me
Nando's do one that's insane how so many
people get into the mix of something
like this it's just over girls bully
homeless man and then I fed them get on
what do you mean like the like like
picking aside I think it's interesting
to listen to but it's not enough for me
to like go in and fight for either one
if you weren't there huh yeah cuz I
don't I don't know what's going on like
how can you be so sure I guess my thing
is like you who's commenting from
Seattle or whatever you read this story
and you get pissed off and you pick a
side how can you even pick a side like I
lean more towards Sally but I can't
fight for Sally because I don't know
Sally might be lying because Sally could
have just been jealous of these three
young girls for some odd reason and then
she you know who knows cuz I don't even
know what what the video that Sally took
like what that contains so I have no
clue I feel like the people that are
supporting like the teenage girls or
other people around their age and like
they probably could relate to the girls
on this sense of like oh I know what
it's like to be misunderstood I know
what it's like when like you know older
people like don't understand where
you're coming through one side of yeah
they always see one side and it's like
maybe because it struck a hard-enough
chord with them that they're like okay I
need to say something because if I don't
say anything then no one will listen
grown-ups are all the same that's right
teens are people too sometimes what is
[ __ ] up though if if they really did
that in the homeless man didn't get
Nando's that's like the worst thing like
I love Nando's right cuz I specially cuz
I don't have it out here if someone told
me they were gonna get me some Nando's
and I don't get that [ __ ] that's the
same thing as telling me that like hey
you want a million dollars or guess what
ours is just a prank
Nando's sounds like Mexican food for
some reason it's Portuguese português I
think it is cuz Perry Perry's supposed
to be a Portuguese thing that went to
Africa
yeah the African Portuguese he broke
down the whole history of para period
I forgot the bags are your life but I
remember it was so passionate uh the
place in Burbank I don't remember but
she was just like this guy sound my
whole [ __ ] now aren't you regretting
it that you didn't listen that you can't
consider but I remember like I was upset
because he couldn't explain some
mothership but he could tell me the
whole history of Perry Perry I forgot
why do you leave your socks on the floor
no Melissa let me tell you bout paper
shaking right it was a couple with
something else but I forgot I forgot one
you know how girls collection you know
maybe that's the [ __ ] up oh that's a
[ __ ] like JA [ __ ] doesn't think you
bring out any time next thing you know
is just go holds a real bag well the
[ __ ] comes ready to go we like to
collect a lot of things but then with
those things pedimental with those
things we have nice memories too you do
tell them a nice memory that we had ah
do it you said that I look very pretty
all the time that's not a memory
not one instance no no you just know
today in the morning you said that I
always look beautiful that was a memory
today I thought you're about to say I've
never said that [ __ ] something nice that
he said about me the pettiness came out
yeah [ __ ] yeah miss Queen petty yep
petty wat dude daddy Chitty Wok yeah
hashtag petty [ __ ]
[Music]